This is
"The Super Slow Show."
How many times?
Just be like...
I'm gonna be like this.
( music playing )
We a got spinner,
we a got dropper.
Most importantly, though,
new lab coats.
( gasps )
Come on!
That's come off
too much easily.
Flippin' A.
Yeah but most importantly,
new lab coat.
I probably ripped it.
That's--
What's that?
For the next 12--
I don't know why I'm waving.
For the next 12 weeks.
For the next 12 weeks,
we'll--
we'll be releasing
48 different videos.
48?
48, mate.
Welcome to a brand-new week
of "The Super Slow Show."
Dan, are you hungry?
I think we both know
the answer to that one.
Excellent.
Dan, are you hungry?
I think we both know
the answer to that one.
Excellent.
What have we got cooking up?
This is the great
British slow-off.
See what I did there?
Using food--
Oh ( bleep )!
Hello, I'm Gav!
- And I'm Dan.
- Yeah.
I just don't like the--
You know
on the Newton's cradle
where the ball hits
the other ball and it does that?
It didn't do that.
I'm trying to push here.
There's no movement
whatsoever.
Here's the ball...
- We're ready, okay.
- Go for it.
I'm gonna drop, now!
Now.
- Here we go.
- Now.
( sighs )
What a wet blanket.
Oh, look!
It don't thrill me.
Oh, it's wet bread.
- ( Gav gagging )
- Yeah!
Hey!
Gavin.
- ( Gav coughs )
- ( Dan laughs )
He hates wet bread.
Look at that wet bread
flying through there.
Imagine it's quite moist.
- Probably like--
- All right, we don't have
to go into detail.
( grunting )
If you just joined us, Dan is
looking inside a giant Jell-O.
It's a totally
normal sight.
This is like a Tuesday
for us.
( grunts )
I need to be washed off.
Do you think you could get up
the slide like that?
I don't want to.
( bleep ), man!
That'd be like polishing
dog ( bleep ).
It'd be pointless.
Dan, over the years
we've put you
inside some very
strange things, haven't we?
I like being
inside strange things.
Should we--
That's like way to--
way too much, right?
Is that way--
that's not PG at all.
Man:
Gotta have the first one,
so maybe without this time?
- Okay.
- All right.
I thought it was--
Like you only know
what I'm talking about
if you're
at the correct age.
That's perfect, right?
We'll do one without it.
How about that?
This is our impact point.
Preferably within this like
three foot, three foot--
blah.
( bleep ).
So this is our impact point
within this three to foot--
( bleep )!
So this is
our impact point--
Wait.
I'm sorry I'm laughing.
( grunts )
It's like a sort of
futuristic ball gown.
( laughs )
What?
- You look like--
- A futuristic ball gown.
You look like a candle
that someone left in a window.
Look at my hair
through there.
Look at.
It's disgusting.
Now you look
like someone
who was born out of the top
of a mushroom.
My hands are tied.
Ah... God!
Do you want me to help--
do you want me to hold on
and you crouch?
See if you can yank it up.
Is it harder than this
to get into a corset?
( grunts )
It's like trying
to get into some jeans
you haven't worn
for five years.
Do you reckon
I could drink this?
Probably.
Not easily.
Let me just--
( laughs )
- Oh the flaming--
- Do you sometimes look
at footage like this
and think I'm glad
that I do that for a living?
Well, I don't do this
for a living,
if I did it'd be TV dinners
under a bare light bulb.
Today you're doing it
for a living.
In you mom's basement
listening to Rush?
Listening to Rush,
"Moving Pictures."
Yeah, probably
their best album.
Man:
Fellas, can you do--
That was great.
Can you just give me
a condensed version
like about half the length
of that?
- Sure.
- All right, here we go refill.
Still rolling.
Quiet!
Love how that video started off
as a video about balloons
ended up just being
a giant fireball.
Thanks for watching.
Sorry, one more time.
( screams )
- Oh, my God!
- Look at that!
Go on.
It twined my nose completely.
It almost carried me off
by my nose.
- I was there, right?
- What happened?
I was there-- oh.
Oh, it's a pin!
There's a pin
in the floor.
Oh, savage.
( music playing )
Hi guys, click here to catch up
on our latest adventures.
I barely survived
so I hope you like 'em.
Dan did complain a lot.
I do all the work.
Most of it.
- You do 90%
- I do all the work.
All right, fine.